WILL: THE NUMBERS ARE
STAGGERING, BORDER PATROL
SOURCES ESTIMATE $14 MILLION IS
A FROM CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS
AND TRAFFICKING ON THE US
MEXICAN BORDER INCLUDING WOMEN,
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES BEING
TRAFFICKED.
LERA LOGAN HAS SMUGGLED THE
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
THE CARTELS, WE THINK ABOUT
DRUGS, NARCOTICS, NARCOTICS
SMUGGLING.
THAT IS ONLY A PORTION OF THEIR
BUSINESS, HUMAN SMUGGLING AND AN
INCREASING PIECE OF THE PIE
WOULD TOUCH THEIR REVENUE.
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND THIS HAS
BEEN GOING ON FOR SOME TIME.
THIS IS A MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR
BUSINESS, THE MOST POWERFUL
ORGANIZATION, WHAT MOST
AMERICANS DON’T UNDERSTAND IS
WHEN THEY SEE THE MASS FLOW OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE BORDER, IN
SLAVERY IN THE WORLD, I’VE SEEN
THIS WITH MY OWN EYES, SO MANY
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS WILL HAVE A
LITTLE CARD IN THEIR POCKET OR A
NUMBER WRITTEN DOWN, A BANK
ACCOUNT FOR THE CARTEL.
IF YOU HAVEN’T PAID ALL YOUR
FEES BY THE TIME YOU CROSS THEY
WILL COLLECT.
YOU AND YOUR FRIENDS TALKING
ABOUT WORKING TWO JOBS AND SO
HARD-WORKING, GUESS WHAT, THEY
ARE WORKING TWO JOBS A LOT OF
TIME BECAUSE SO MUCH OF THEIR
MONEY IS GOING BACK TO THOSE
CARTELS AND NOW SOME OF THEM ARE
WEARING WRISTBANDS LINKED TO
DATABASES IN COMPUTERS, THE
CARTEL WAS ABLE TO TRACK YOU
WHEREVER YOU ARE AND THEY CAN
KEEP TRACK OF YOUR FAMILY ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE BORDER.
NO ESCAPE FROM THESE THINGS.
WILL: THAT IS JUST A SEGMENT OF
THE POPULATION.
IT IS THE MOST VALUABLE STRETCH
OF GROUND IN THE WORLD AND THE
FACT THAT WHETHER OR NOT YOU ARE
FROM MEXICO OR CENTRAL AMERICA,
THEY ARE PAYING ANOTHER RATE.
>> THE CARTELS ARE EXTREMELY
GOOD AT EXPLOITING EVERY AVENUE.
IF YOU’RE COMING AS AN ADULT
MALE IT IS HARDER AND THEY CAN
CHARGE MORE MONEY.
THE MEXICANS DON’T WANT CHINESE
PEOPLE THERE SO WHEN THE US
TRIES TO SEND THEM BACK MEXICO
IS NOT TAKING THEM.
CHINA, ANYONE WITH CUSTOMS AND
BORDER PROTECTION
SPECIAL-INTEREST ALIENS OR OTHER
VICTIMS, THEY TRAVEL WITH MUCH
HIGHER NUMBERS AND SOMETHING
ELSE INTERESTING WE JUST
LEARNED, IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE BORDER, JUST ACROSS FROM DEL
RIO, TEXAS, THE RATE IS LOWER
THAN IT IS IN MCALLEN AND RIO
GRANDE VALLEY, WHAT THIS
INDICATES IS THE CARTEL CONCERT
WHATEVER PRICE THEY WANT TO,
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE COMING FROM
HAITI OR COUNTRIES LIKE THAT
THEY KNOW YOU’RE MORE DESPERATE,
AND THEY CHARGE YOU MORE.
WILL: I WANT TO ACCESS -- THE
PRESS ACCESS, BLOCKING OUT
SUPPORTERS FROM SEEING WHAT WAS
GOING ON, PHOTOGRAPHERS COVERING
THIS FOR YEARS SAYING IT HAS
NEVER BEEN LIKE THIS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> THAT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
PHOTOJOURNALIST, HE WROTE AN
EDITORIAL IN THE WASHINGTON POST
WHO SAID HE NEVER ENCOUNTERED
THIS USING A LONG LENS.
WHAT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT IS
HIDING THE INESCAPABLE FACT THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING WHAT BIDEN DID IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND WHAT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION DID
WHICH IS THEY HAVE TO AT SOME
POINT HOLD PEOPLE, WHEN YOU HOLD
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WHETHER IT IS
BEHIND BARS OR IN A CAGE OR
CHAIN-LINK FENCE OR PLASTIC
PODS, RELEASED YESTERDAY, IN
PHOTOGRAPHS THEY SHOWED AND
CONGRESSMAN HENRY CUELLAR
RELEASING PHOTOGRAPHS FROM
RELEASING PHOTOGRAPHS FROM THE
BORDER IT NEVER LOOKED, IT PLAYS
ON YOUR HEARTSTRINGS, IT IS
EMOTIONAL.
I HAVE BEEN DOWN THERE SO MANY
TIMES IN MY HEART IS BROKEN FOR
THESE FAMILIES BUT IT DOESN’T
CHANGE THE FACT THAT THERE IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY LEVEL OF
HYPOCRISY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T
WANT THE COUNTRY TO SEE THE
SCALE OF THE CRISIS.
THEY DON’T WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
IT IS A CRISIS AND DON’T WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEY ARE DOING WHAT
DONALD TRUMP DID USING THE SAME
AGENTS, THE SAME PROTOCOLS
EXCEPT ONE DISTINCT DIFFERENCE.
THEY ARE RELEASING A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE INTO THE COUNTRY WITHOUT
GIVING THEM A NOTICE LEAVING IT
UP TO THOSE PEOPLE AND BYPASSING
THE ILLEGAL SITUATION AND MADE
THE BORDER EFFECTIVELY OPEN.
I HAD A COLLEAGUE WHO HAS BEEN
WAITING FOR FIVE YEARS TO HOLD
HIS CHILDREN.
HE IS HERE LEGALLY, 6 MONTHS OLD
WHEN HE LEFT, SHE IS TURNING 6
IN APRIL AND THAT MAN HAS BEEN
TORTURED.
HE LOVES HIS CHILDREN MORE THAN
ANYTHING AND I DON’T HEAR
ANYBODY TALKING ABOUT FAMILIES
THAT HAVE BEEN SEPARATED IN THAT
WAY BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM NOW.
TODD: LERA LOGAN HAS NO AGENDA,